hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
to John is that you
I'd recognize that backside anywhere
John please tell me that's actually you
and not somebody else John how you doing
buddy
Oh pal I feel pretty fast look at you so
you're just lazing about you got any
leads I got something you see them sure
boy see chef is a shepherd now baby come
on
well where exactly we go collect
something help us get some sheep you
know that attempt to seem all enigmatic
and interesting and might work for Dutch
but for you it just makes you look
stupid
come along hmm I know my back the train
job was a star but we need more money
mmm mmm get back to Blackwater and
collect I'm here to tell you we try to
collect that money any time soon it'll
come with a noose I was worried you'd
say that that says that says a lot
that's his gift saying that oh yeah what
do you mean by that
I was surprised pony once now I'm a
workhorse
listen Duchess but but well you was at
that thing in Blackwater we already seen
Pinkertons here new centuries coming
this life this way we're the last I
reckon we ain't long for
and that's the way it goes I guess me
yes all right
where are we going just need to pick up
something hmm it's funny cuz it seems
like Arthur is recognizing the signs am
I missing something
am i miss remembering something that
like I could have sworn that John liked
one of the first big names that he was
hunting down was Arthur no no that seems
strange I can't really remember anyway I
know I got a brush you horsey horsey but
uh moonpool we got stuff to do so I'll
see you in just a bit
oh we gotta get shiny and again okay
alright I have to go by sniper today
hello again ooh I will indeed look at
your catalogue sir oh yeah all right
what have we got in the way of a rifle I
love that how they do this this is super
fun
Hey it is a courageous man who shoots
from afar manufactured to the higher
standards for the pleasures of shooting
from afar a powerful tool for pleasure
the luxury sound of deafening joy Oh
rifle of choice over both the holy and
unholy ambition
oh go to the page is not on it okay all
right well rolling block it is you got
it
Oh free free for me Wow
well what do we got four components
barrel rifling improved rifling oh I
like the sound of improved I like that
well got improved scope it's so big it's
a short little cutie a little cutie
their own uh growing boy who's a big boy
I gotta go for the big it's very
unpractical but I'm gonna go for it
anyway all right basic grain straight
grain that doesn't look better wide if
they say one thing about my grain its
wide it's as wide as it is thick rap no
rap
yes rap of course I'm gonna get a rap on
that bad boy oh hell yeah let's get to
it
okay well I'm good thank you sure styles
Oh
oh my god okay well this is a bit too
much I'm not gonna go for those because
I can't even be bothered about that
ammunition all right
high velocity well I am a basic [ __ ] so
I'm gonna go with just basic [ __ ] ammo
as much as I would love the fancy stuff
oh I know I just abused it so I'm just
gonna buy the good old basic stuff all
right good enough for me I'm doing the
accent again I just roll into it I don't
know when I'm doing it when I'm not
doing it so if you guys catch me doing
it just say so
just shame me for it I can't be bothered
to stop alright let's go baby
hey John John John Oh John there you are
yeah I got a sniper rifle whatever
reason you wanted me to get a sniper
rifle I'm not a hundred percent sure but
I got it
so mm-hmm we shall see where we headed
John John where we headed you tell me
earlier why are you being so cagey about
all this donkey
oh it's playing some goddamn game you
ain't the one taking Jack on fishing
trips oh you like if you say the boy
ain't yours what's the difference you
probably only run off again why are you
so interested in my life
think you got one of your own just do
one thing or another not be two people
that wants that saw ups that simple you
know that as well as anyone same is with
you and that girl what was her name Mary
that was different
no it ain't just to say anyway for the
love of God you tell me what you've got
me doing here before I turn around and
hit the priests there's a herd of sheep
coming down to auction from Emerald
ranch pokin town we're saying the owners
trying to stamp out every farm from here
to answer yeah I know that place
okay so what I'm gonna do shoot the guy
herd number we're gonna shoot us a
couple sheep what do we do what are we
doing it why did I need a sniper rifle
for this why do I need to be the
courageous man shooting from afar with
the sniper rifle with a big booming
noise yeah and also you didn't take your
son fishing your wife asked me to take
your son fishing so why aren't you
taking your son fishing seems like
you're getting mad for all the wrong
reasons they're done and sorry horsey
just ran through that cactus
okay whatever used to cut this beautiful
oh my god that is just a beautiful and I
love the waves of heat that you're
starting to see now the weather system
god I know it hey there's that horse
okay a car I'll call that crossroad
horse because I'll always mark exactly
where I need to be excuse me so
binoculars could have done it too don't
know why I gotta be lethal at range was
it town that's not Valentine what is
that town is that Valentine oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh oh my god
oh my god it's so pretty
sorry what sorry I was very busy okay
all right
so you want me to shoot near them Oh
boom
looks like one of them don't scare too
easy
put another shot in close tween his legs
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there goes the shapes
okay goodbye
alright sure I guess you really did
think about ranching let's go get us
some sheep buddy our best buddy you got
it it's probably a lot harder than we
think
all right come here she pees hey shape
your way face
hey shape baby peas a little ball Pape
it come out this chip I'm gonna blast
sue you I don't know if I'm supposed to
last through you am I supposed to last
through you uh-huh okay
oh I see him on the mini-map hey hey
guys guys get get let's get Adam Hey
yeah all right come on
you see peas I'm gonna do a sweep Drive
buying a sweet sketch get out here all
come on come on yeah oh come on I'm
getting fancy with my horse yo hey they
got a little writing on - OH
riding the cactus come on come on come
on come on yo I don't know if I'm
supposed to say y'all but it feels right
when I say y'all so I'm saying yo all
right yo yo come on
oh you know what why don't you leave the
sheep to me you ride shank keep watch
for any trouble I brought you in on this
it'll be quicker this way trust me
Saint the right time for you yeah you
better be done arguing shout at the herd
oh my yellow these sheep for a little
bit Marston okay guts I studied these
sheep no bill where are you going Marcin
come on now you sheep come on there we
go on the road again
oh you cuties you're just a bunch of
cuties ain't you you're a bunch of
cuties alright no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no oh let's go let's
go let's go come on you sheep I'm on
sheeple let's keep it movin let's keep
it moving guys let's keep it movin
alright come on oh come on I go whose
sheep herding could be so fun they're
not run over any of these sheep damn it
alright get going don't fall off that
mountain now don't fall off the mountain
don't fall off the mountain bill let me
slow Perdue come on you slowpokes
wait don't come on come on hurry up
hurry up you think you think like God
you know you're like the people
expecting other people to be be out here
this be like hey wait well then we lost
one it get get get get yeah get get get
skadoodle skadoodle skadoodle skadoodle
come on
go go go go go there you go there you go
see it ain't so bad it ain't so bad
ain't so bad anyway yeah now I got it I
know
oh what a bunch of beautiful animals
maybe I don't know where are they going
anyway there's someone that's supposed
to be receiving them oh I get it right
in the fence all right whoo Marsten
careful careful Marston careful you
ain't got the fancy maneuvers that I got
close her up
so what happened to the original
farmhands I don't know and I won't say
nothing to nobody
excuse me sure I'll excuse you for 25%
do you want me to put another hole in
your head folks swing for rustling
livestock 25% 15 20 18 go on now I mean
that's a fair deal he knows what's up he
knows what's up
man I loves quick negotiation 25 dude
why is he upset what's more important
bribe that's funny yeah these two
squabbling like this they could be
friends they've got so much in common I
don't I just don't know why Arthur's
being such a prick about it have you
been Marsten's thing good and we're just
waiting to get some pay if you shake
Leopold
my good friend as long as you're here
why don't you and John go make sure
there ain't no funny business of course
gentlemen drink sure nothing like
talking to old Strauss to make you want
to blow your own brains out I should
have left him where I found him all
those years ago
bookish little Austrian fresh off the
boat his eyes out on stock well I guess
the Dutch vanderlin finishing school has
some strange graduates it does to your
good health thank you
probably tuberculosis you know what I'm
talking about
[Music]
I'm not a man to be messed with by the
like see okay
what do you think well you start
spinning the yarn when I think the
moments right I'll make a wait where are
you going man please gentlemen this is a
terrible mistake this is a case of
mistaken identity
what is worse than admonishing a man for
the sins of another who wants to be the
Messiah here we go here we go here we go
here we go ready Oh No
I wanted to get better shots going off
but that didn't work out too nicely he's
dead I'm not shooting this lefty style I
forgot how much I like the pistol god
damn it's been so long since I used the
pistol
never mind the pistols wimpiest [ __ ]
missile can't kill nobody
where's my rifle let me get the rifle
back at oh I didn't know this game had
destructible physics oh hell yeah yeah
we don't run where are they Rossi okay
[Music]
there we go I need a cigarette hang on I
got to refill my meter
I gotta look good when I'm doing this
hang on hang on hang for it wait for it
and there you go
All Right see ya whoa wait I don't know
about that one
let's see who else we got here playing a
bow me okay up bang Oh me there we go
that's good stuff oh hey how's it going
bang oh boy
bang a boo me bang oh you're not dead
yet ain't you okay
Oh bang let's see foamy playing in the
heart let's see and oh hang on let me
reload here hand Oh No
really okay go for that yeah it seems
pretty good oh hey a bang a pull me up
banging ere we go more hey guys don't
let up daddy then I'm getting much
better at the controls than I originally
was I say as I miss buying anymore
that's a lot of dead men it's no time to
lose no time to loot I guess hey
[Music]
oh you got it I got Strauss why don't
you get Strauss right around me groans
go gates growth you got a snake bite
that I can suck out I'm real good at
that you want me to suck the bullet out
I can definitely do that here we go dude
you gotta push this card a little bit
closer guys would have been a great help
if you had done that but okay
these horses on the back of John's horse
oh okay well fine then excuse me pardon
me I know we're in a hurry but I just
want to do this right
don't kicked in the head I saw a guy
[Music]
let's go we're still shoot how in the
hell are you I got to deal with this
nonsense now god damn it where's my
rifle
uh-huh and how did that get more lawmen
in this town they got a run out
eventually I guess we're done in
Valentine forever huh
damn right when we were about to get
money from the Sheep oh boy the wall
what is GTA cops
word my horse go um oh yes I am I am
trying to make a run for it
are you by yourself buddy shouldn't move
DUP yeah yeah yeah horses come on horsey
good God horsey horsey horsey you
bastard
what you doing horse what you doing what
are you doing
horse huh let's go let's go let's go
okay yeah I'm running away
oh yeah
yeah oh he is not having a good day it's
okay it's okay buddy who's buying queasy
I'll kick you
where's that house that they were
building over there hey buddy listen
listen listen bang you probably should
rethink your life choices I mean I'm not
going to so someone's got among us and
how do you make your horse just auto run
that's what I want to know sometimes it
does sometimes it does not
whoa whoa Bessie whoa Bessie whoa that's
why we weren't Auto running okay that's
good to know
I think we're good I think we're in the
clear probably maybe maybe not I'm not
100% sure but yeah I gotta get give me
some nutritional what nuts where's my I
sold all of my nutritional whatnots god
dammit I'm an idiot well alright I am
dumb I guess I just gotta cook some meat
or something like that hunt for food
instead of money I don't know what I'm
gonna be able to do that but so I got to
get this gosh darn marker off my map
okay it'll probably tell me when camp is
lit after I lose the law that's probably
when it's gonna do that well that
definitely is a story moving forward so
mr. Caldwell cold well mr. bell big
belly big balls mr. small ball really
doesn't like us stealing from him so
that's his problem
oh this is where the camp was how here
it is hello hello Bill Williamson how
are you doing you handsome Silla I gotta
take a nap or something
get some food hey Dutch
so why are we still here Dutch shouldn't
we be moving almost immediately now
shouldn't we be as fast as we possibly
can getting out of here
nice join the comm you we stop when we
find someplace sensible shake them
that's following us and while oh this is
lying low turned into a bunch of killers
I mean it ain't even got the delusion of
being anything but a bunch of killers we
are just trying to survive Hosea we
don't have a choice
so we movin yeah this land soon
damn right we'll constipated as you mica
told me of a place we can lie low
oh yeah Mike is the one to trust to bury
Creek he said okay maybe you and Charles
can go take a look clear off anyone you
find before the whole lot of us move in
looking so conspicuous now we're gonna
do that I don't know start dancing looks
like I turned into a goddamn errand boy
you have turned into my son you worry
because I worry we are just the same
getting a little culty getting less
about how you know I roll it together
good more like maybe a little bit crazy
maybe boss is getting a little crazy I
mean I love boss don't get me wrong
Boston my favorite boss but uh maybe
boss not be so good so more maybe boss
needs to be uh I don't know run around
the room alright boys we're on it boss
don't worry about nothing boss alright I
guess we are
we'd already pushed our luck too far
before that mess we just made it
Valentine I can't wait for you I'm busy
[Music]
Creek just to give it a look make sure
it's cleared good place to lie low for a
while I've only known in a few months
but wait talks I never thought I'd see
him one the heads low
there's too many of us for that and
there ain't no wait Dutch is gonna just
hide away in a cave somewhere goes
against everything he stands for
that'd be admitting we're nut morning
lowdown criminals which we are you don't
have to tell me so where does it end
where does one in
running Dutch don't see it is running
call it what you want I don't know
before put enough time and distance
between you and the problem eventually
it went away I think that must be it up
ahead the old dried-up Creek seems very
open yeah it does
make sure to be the best in the rain
neither well take a look around
hmm well I mean it doesn't look great
why would I slow it down what do we got
to slow it down for well you speed it up
you got anything to drink by the way cuz
I am just dying of hunger and thirst if
this seems like a terrible idea to be
here why would we why would we be here
this is like the worst possible place to
be okay so let me get a good look with
my bye knocks let me just take a gander
here yep that guy is when we double
check dead all right I'm ready for
business
okey-dokey whatever you say partner oh
my god
yeah you never know with places like
this whatever
[Music]
hello okay Yello okay hmm there's
something something up here I see you
but I see you it's okay it's okay
come out of there you okay
this is awkward
he shader are you okay Josh it's German
no now go on girl
get out of here we know someone men last
night yeah where did they take them
hey no business of ours I don't even
speak their language you ain't as tough
and dances all that come on yeah Arthur
you big dumb root help them out we know
somebody that speaks him for German gosh
Lupul you're better than that won't be
huh come on tracks
let me see with my eagle eyes huh oh you
are correct
[Music]
we got Pinkertons bringing down our
necks we should be moving that's not how
you are okay it's a train track do you
know what that means
okay this is a nice close look I knew
that I could see you with my glowy
vision you mean you don't have glowy
vision cuz I certainly do and it's weird
[Music]
if you ask me give me a second I've got
the special vision apparently you don't
whatever yeah whatever I see him do cuz
back sit it right in front of jack
that kid it's gonna be tough for him
yeah but he has more folks looking out
for him most of the rest of us had
growing up
sploosh worlds we ledin are they still
gonna be there when they get back are
they gonna be huddled up underneath the
batch seems like earth it's got a bit of
a complex do you need my help
oh wait there's two tracks I guess yeah
I guess
Oh Oh what I thought I would have
thought that we thought we would have go
a little sneaky like let's take a look
okay whatever fine then sure nobody here
okay oh now we're getting off the horse
oh I was just a bit early about that
okay whatever screw you man where's this
guy I don't know but you know something
this is a better can't spot them back
there much easier to defend oh hello
[Music]
quick cut him free let's get out of here
okay all right
are you German okay all right then well
you're about to see three dead men oh
wait I just got my shotgun all right
well we're gonna do this uh we're gonna
go in guns blazing look I am a
professional cuz watch some of this boy
Cobb point
blink boiling uh blink and a blink and
choo choo choo choo all right handsome a
[Music]
shoot this guy please I don't shoot my
other guy wait no what the what the hell
what the hell
there we go now we're just the one gun I
don't know how that happened but I'm
happy for it ow
can I hide please thank you
[Music]
you're not dead right mass that's how
you know they're dead there we go
you gonna run I hit him twice god damn
it I didn't have my good gun okay I
guess he's going alright let me let me
hang on I gotta get my good gun out of
this I get this sniper rifle here there
we go
actually let me go for uh I'm not gonna
do that
let me go for sniper rifle I'm coming
hang on mr. German man where are you
maybe I don't know if we are Mike you
might not do go find Dutch get the
caravan to divert here this spot your
work force I agree hmm okay hang on man
you gotta help me do the dirty business
of looting all these lovely people
you give me something good I need some
food I need drink
give me some goddamn drink man can you
please no can you please
there we go straddle that body there we
go
65 cents horse stimulant now what would
happen if I drank four stimuli you would
you think it worked for me I turn horse
like in anyway nothing nothing to drink
yet you don't think this is wrong on me
mister man these guys are dead nothing I
can do for them now it is amazing like
just how much in videogames like just
death everywhere like what's my kill
count at this point it's got to be huge
hey there's a doc yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah family yeah I mean I got a I got a
pic German Beckett
oh what the [ __ ] hell happened okay
oh your teeth posing huh okay all right
okay we're gonna pretend like all that's
good to go
righty-ho then let's not cut through the
main trees let's go on the something
trail oh god this is pretty this is
pretty in a different way than the big
landscape because my god this is a
faithful God oh my god it's foggy it's
foggy just the concept of that it's
foggy now that's so cool
god damn and I love this game so much
every part of it I love this game I
don't even care if I'm slipping in and
out of the accent hey you leave that
rabbit alone he's mine I love this game
crunch it's so well made stomp yeah I
would get those deer but I don't have
time right now it's probably gonna be
real good real good
farming anyway hey I got your uh
find a via supervision my Liebling yeah
I wanna get out of here this place ain't
safe
[Laughter]
thank you sure whoa feed and on cats
dunk it's a gold bar yes it was a
pleasure yeah it's like a solid gold bar
holy crap yeah no wonder they robbed
that guy and they just travel on their
own it's so dangerous of course they
would
oh my god okay whatever I don't know who
the dead guy in the river was but I
guess it doesn't matter at this point
miss scrimshaw mr. Pearson put everyone
to work make this place a home well I
don't know where the hell we are but we
are going to make the best of it
alright I guess we are it's beautiful
I'll give it that man they keep picking
the best scenic locations and I love it
Chapter three
oh my god Chapter three we are not even
close to done with this game
we're not even close I bet it's like a
1012 chapter game oh my god we're not
even close and I love it I love it I
love it I love it I love it I love it I
love it
a few days later it's good still yeah
wash my beard so long enough get that
out of Golding it can be sold in any
fence for a large profit where are
fences I want to sell it a fence where
our cell defense there's a gold there's
a dollar sign here somewhere okay
whatever I'm gonna go see what Dutch
wants
oh hey Dutch you were right by where I
was never mind out there hey boss how
are you doing boss good to see you you
see boss many times I see I'm boring we
lost men back there we have lofty goals
Arthur we're trying to reform society to
a kind of true or better way now of
course there's gonna be casualties we're
thieves you know world don't want us no
more
we are dreamers in an ever duller world
of facts now I'll give you that but come
on okay Dutch around here okay what you
want to go fishing now I went fishing
with Jack it was kinda nice I guess but
at the same time I feel like maybe we
should think about the long-term future
of us try to get the bounties off our
heads and whatnot and who's what's it
you know you know how it'd be okay
you're just not gonna talk to me anymore
Dutch is that it this do I have to fill
the silence on my own he's just gonna
okay no I can tell Hosea is gonna be
troubling Hosea is creating not not
josé's greeting but Hosea is splitting
from Dutch in a bad way and I think
everyone can read the room about that
one Hosea is gonna betray Dutch and then
it's gonna be a big split in the party
and then everyone's gonna be like it's
not worth it oddly enough arthur is
weirdly positioned okay I guess I won't
follow them
curious couple and our unruly son
it feels good here you did well fine in
that spot Archer for Charles and me it's
like I can breathe again thick and soupy
as this air is might even do your
whistling pipe some good Hosea I was
watching in this country with Bessie
feels like a lifetime ago it was a
lifetime ago but what a life we have
lived now well we have fought especially
both of you I hope so
but now when things are desperate we
have to stick with the plan
make enough money then find somewhere
where nobody will find us we don't have
to hide like where I got some ideas
hatching but I need you with me not
against me both of you horse still we do
need money so keep a low profile
especially in the local town after
Valentine I want everyone on best
behavior here no no trouble you knew us
over the soil and the rocks see what
turns up Dutch we've got to be discreet
imagine what a smooth rich simpletons
there must be down here you'll be able
to play a little nothing but give me
greater pleasure but no buts
not today
we fish and we enjoy the day okay boss
you got it boss we go
I'm already enjoying myself tenfold oh
I'm cool cooler than cool hey hey how's
it going hey how you doing hey how you
doing
you're cooler the more you say how you
doing hey are you doing over there you
doing it you good day a good day we're
gonna go fishing hey how you doing how
are you boys fine this is quite some
country you have here we like it well
enough pokey McIntosh at your service
Lee great this is my deputy Archibald
McGregor it's good to meet you
you were Scott partly the best nothing
too terrible I trust he was accused of
running a gold mining investment scam oh
no no no no I'm sure he wasn't that he
is a magician I know where he's a fool
but he is not a bad fella
now can we can we just
okay more scandal
I'm on it buddy
okay I will flip the Train I'm dude we
can't have more scandal I mean the horse
is doing all the work
almost come on now oh okay all right
which side this side does the only side
I know of I'm doing my best
seems like you might be doing something
all right listen you you started this
conversation off real bad
All Right see ya hey buddies their
bodies their bodies bodies bodies bodies
mr. Callen and that's your service come
on guys Kostov a you let's go bowling
come on
why are you doing running away from me
hey you think you're gonna run away from
Callaghan no way no how or you think hey
barrel going to stop me
there's no way daba caba know what you
run oh hello alright friend a bunk
I'll miss me and I hit you back one two
buckle my shoe
there you go how about you get thrown
off the train there friend oh but both
it'll rope-a-dope and there goodbye okay
yeah okay you got it
uno mas hey listen you don't need to do
that here come this way friend you're
good I'm good
alright let's do this alright well
alright
yeah I guess I got a bull [ __ ] what do I
got it
[Music]
wow wow that could have been a stab in
the head
Wow
Rick this guy is gonna come why don't
okay listen listen guys I oh there we go
finally now I've got it I'm getting
better at the fighting system there we
go
look I'm gonna try screw you buddy
oh and my opportunity Punk all right
well he's down yeah everything's fine
just a few stab wounds I'm gonna be
worse off than Marston
bring them out here yeah yeah it's fine
let me out
Callahan coming through Anders Anderson
8 where did you get a horse yeah okay
sure
slum law man and heart that's me of
course of course I have to admit I'd
hazard a guess you've served the lawyer
yourself at some point on your right
here these tobacco fields this is part
of Calicut Hall biggest state belongings
to the grave family looks bone-dry yes
we are in dire need of some rain rounds
here let me tell you la créme lived in
calico hall for generations fine people
my family's been working for them for
years
sheriff grace the one I know best of
course but they own half the businesses
in town which town roads sir you don't
know it where we're headed right now
ain't what it was before the war but it
has its charms I'm sure you already know
of the braithwaite's I guess said just
got down here another big family in
these parts they have an estate west of
here awful people truly awful they've
been fighting with the Grays for as long
as I can remember sounds like quite the
place you got here
yeah sound pretty nice anyway okay so
where are the other guys you know the
guys that got thrown off the train and
the guy that got hit in the back of the
head by that iron bar do we just not
care that they're probably dead or do we
just carry on now
touches ask the gang not to use weapons
or cause trouble in roads all right fine
I guess whatever if we have two nice
horse
so uh immune from the law now okay all
right partner hello how are you
your idiot friend is free to go no more
trouble from you partner I promise you
this was Miss Sun does want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart I'll pretend
to appreciate mr. McIntosh it has been a
real pleasure the mostly good citizens
of Rhodes we welcome well we're just
honored to be here and make your friend
behave we got enough trouble from some
of the residents old-timers who've gone
sadly to seed and lost their dignity Oh
terrible care I will keep this fellow on
the straight and there
come back and see us sometime soon
excuse me gentlemen
all right you got it these better be
ugly rooms is it true you were seen
talking to that wretched Penelope
Braithwaite wretched whenever P
Braithwaite town behind the church
between the two families his lot
marrying cousins I have missed you boys
I've heard about bounty no there's been
a price on my head for 13 years it'll
take a months to find us down here and
it seems like we can have a little sport
they're good bounties where you hear
this some fellas I met to the camp near
the state lines that there was talk of
it in bars in the north and west for 500
miles
super super agents I'd love to meet one
it's just talk I'm sure yes bounties you
say Arthur's is like I am so sick of all
of this [ __ ] I just wanted to go fishing
[Music]
I just wanted to go fishing okay okay
honestly honestly I really actually I'm
good on fishing
someplace fair enough it looks like it's
you and me old man you know what that's
fair enough - because frankly I didn't
really want to go fishing I was
complaining to complain I'd rather go
take a bath get a good scrub from some
random lady that sounds more like
mouthing oh and finally all the stores
are excuse me all right sorry I didn't
mean to interrupt you but everyone is
naked everyone's naked okay well then
that's weird hey can I sell my [ __ ] to
you no I'm not looking I'm not looking
at Oprah visions actually I do need some
I'm like
liquor maybe
damn good what I need is I need some
good canned food here
I need apricots that'll do
oh yeah baked beans love me some beans
some corn corn beef I'll take that
somehow that does me good kanpai
pineapples hell yeah oh yeah okay
whatever I'm done here I'm gonna sell my
[ __ ] if you can let me sell my [ __ ]
please may I please excuse you rude
number one but number two I am a law
abiding citizen to the nth degree see ya
anyway no vacancies a will that's sucks
ara and no vacancies there gunsmith over
there actually let me take a look at the
map here and see if I can find some I'm
doing it again goddamn it I'm doing Oh
the stage poked it is open let me go
into the saloon there real quick and
then I can see if there's something
going on there weapons have been
forbidden but that's alright alright so
Looney saloon e1e where's the saloon a
doctor man maybe I could sell some
tonics of some sort doc doc doc in there
doc doc hello doc doc
please stop to look at that guy disgust
yeah all right excuse me I gotta go to
the saloon I gotta give myself a whiskey
yeah you are
doc sug
well listen lady your décolletage is
spilling out oh I thought that was your
skin I didn't know that okay all right
dude hey I was walking by you sack of
crap come on you oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh you're done okay you you want speech
oh yeah wow you're oh you're tough ain't
you not that tough though go get you
come for you there and up we're gone
okay easy enough
cool nuts see you guys
hey doc doc I got real bad doc trying to
somebody nope okay all right then what
am I doing here what am i doing this is
closed down why is it closed down I
didn't close this place down I want a
drink damn it guys you start punching me
as you dumb okay I gotta find some gray
somebody here someone is a gray anybody
here gray oh wait no wait there's a big
gr on my map I got a funny feeling that
the Grays are gonna be up here hey this
is like a Romeo and Juliet kind of thing
going on here with the Grays yeah I got
no idea I thought it was a little closer
than isn't it
all right here we go
horse come here come here horse I where
am I going I thought this was it it is
in town oh okay here we go
no this town's bigger than I thought it
would be yes yes yes fans fans give me
the goddamn fence I want the fence so
badly just oh come here
I need the fence please please fence
horse horse horse horse horse won't bow
come on go go go go go go
don't run I'm sorry look I'm not trying
to hang on we're going swung bolt make
it stop being drunk horse how much have
you drink you've seen the doctor around
here whatever oh wait a minute the fence
is my guy the fence is our guy of course
he's all fit okay yeah da Gus what's
your name
Frank Larrick hello hello oh you're not
our diner patron welcome welcome
don't bother with Alvin shop there all
right I have everything okay okay I
don't but you know I'm gonna sell to you
sure you'll take a solid gold bar and
whatever did
I'm rich I'm rich [ __ ] whoa I'm rich
oh my god I'm rich
finally and finally I've got empty bags
I can actually go hon oh thank you thank
you wait well actually let me see what
he's got to buy didn't didn't there uh
no it's the trapper that has the better
supply bags and stuff like that but let
me just see what this guy's got anyway
that's me I'm a return customer ah baked
beans hell yeah but I don't need those
provisions oh no that was all
they do literally literally let it even
gonna a little bitty lock breaker yes
please literally a canvas sack hood
executioner's hood metal skull mass
psycho mask i'ma buy both cuz I don't
know which one's gonna be better
ooh boys and arrows really really a
homing okay incendiary buckshot yeah oh
my god that is not nearly what I was
hoping for that is ezra god damn
Nicholas why do I have that on me
can I take that off please wait where's
this is an outfit thing oh that's so
stupid all right whatever all right
whatever I wish I had the psycho mask
thanks for your [ __ ] I just wasted all
my money but that's okay because who
cares really all right so we need to
find a trapper to get a better bag but I
don't know where to get a trapper
there's deer out that way I could
definitely go farming but I don't got
time for that so I'm gonna see about the
grades unless there's some other mission
that is more enticing looks like Pearson
back at the cam mic over there mike has
been waiting for a while but mike is
also far away so I think gonna worry too
much about that let's go find ditch
what does Dutch want Dutch go back see
him Oh for the guy there or the greys
it's never on Cal go see what you can
find about the greys the course of true
love oh my god this is gonna be really
romantic and probably a Larry this is
gonna be a hilarious tale of love and
laws and some you
bluch yearning for some other lady there
okay all right I'm down probably gonna
be a writer was or it's gonna be
completely lame but I got a funny
feeling I got a funkalicious feeling
can I please why am I going alright
hoppitty hippitty hippitty hoppitty
hippitty hor full horse she oh right
through that one hope there's no one in
this cornfield because I am about to
destroy them the mission if I go into
the mission we're going to the mission
it'll be like nothing happened
hello hi hey how you doing okay I'm a
history of the region to speak to try
master Bo think he's down there by the
wood store okay alright Bo oh this is
the guy Oh Bo is definitely the guy hey
Bo how how much do you yearn for the
heart of another is this as this what's
going on here bo bo bo you better not be
masturbating in there buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh well Bo Bo must need some
free Bo oh you know me bo it's me
bo oh there's Bob oh hey Bo
hey God excuse me friend
we France not yet but he is hoping I
guess we don't get a lot of traveling
men here and suddenly there's a whole
phalanx of mysterious but strangely
helpful Yankees about place what are you
doing here just looking for work we're
looking for something don't worry your
secret's safe with me
what secret I got a secret of my own are
you secretly normal excuse me
never mind the thing is I don't care if
you killed a whole lot of us and the
braithwaite's don't wanna kill anyone I
love her you know
Savo Penelope but it's impossible love
tends to be complicated
she's a Braithwaite I'm beau gray son of
Tavish gray nephew of Lee gray the
sheriff grandson of old Murdo gray we
graze have been loyal to the state and
murderous to the braithwaite's for so
long now no one can even quite explain
why
beyond blind loyalty and stupidity I'm
supposed to be loyal to some nonsense
while she she's amazing she's like a
woman from the future she's like
tomorrow if tomorrow turns out fine well
I'm sorry for your predicament
would you help I don't wanna get wrong
thinking future seems unseemly I'll pay
I've got money we graze we've always got
money no brains minds of money the edge
of the Braithwaite property take her
this letter this bracelet sure if I know
Penelope sure sure do love to sit what
did your girl you didn't do anything to
me I ran over one of your work hands in
your field they didn't do [ __ ] to me all
right anyway okay here we go all right
little get put down a plea ed about
seeing the ladies sitting round here I'm
cutting through the field again here's
open cross your fingers everybody
like playing minesweeper except with
human lives at risk there was all right
look we're in the clear right let's head
over hey Penelope I'm looking for a lady
by the yeah hi with two butt cheeks
likes to sit that's all I know and if I
seeing a gazebo around here
she's in there 23 hours out of the day I
don't know what other to go by but I'm
giving a bracelet to somebody what the
hell is this what the hell dust storm or
something and whatever probably
pronounced breathe you want a bracelet
probably hell you sit better okay here I
go gambling again not hitting nobody
yeah one of these days I'll actually
take a road somewhere but for right now
I got to take a straight path no matter
what Andy I totally call this is a
hilarious Romeo and Juliet [ __ ]
going on here yeah I'm more likely to be
spotted on horseback Oh what oh wait
okay what what what okay I will leave
I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm
leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm
leaving I will leave I'll leave sir all
right here we go
it's nice and foggy right nobody ain't
gonna see me in the tobacker all right
clunk clunk Oh nobody's gonna see me in
the tobacker
what is this cotton who's gonna see me
in the cotton yeah why does I am nobody
gonna know nothin about nobody
meanwhile those aren't even the Garza's
layer hula
that guy yeah whatever yeah I'm so smart
banana pain and about it seems old
sitting Penelope anybody you guys ain't
seen nothing about nothing nobody Bush
yes all right and by seeing a gazebo
around here come along yeah Penelope you
game you mean got a lot in common I sit
- yeah all right you wouldn't bow you I
think you were gonna sit together real
good set a gazebo I spy no not a gazebo
that's a goddamn Shack
stupid stupid I know the difference
between a gazebo and a shack time to
dive sploosh okay much shallower than I
thought all right here's Moe all right
we're swimming now tick tick tick today
hey Penelope
I got a nice soggy wet bracelet and a
letter for you there buddy
look they're tired you tired Penelope
he's how you sit in Penelope I'm gonna
sneak up on you
hope you don't mind oh wait peek peek
peek creaking hello
I gotta make a visual confirmation that
that's really her yeah wait let's see
something here well Oh can't see much I
don't know if she's sitting or not hang
on I got to get a higher vantage point
this'll do all right I think that sir
dude let their dinner sneaky lack doula
dip for their dirt dirt dirt dirt Oh
and a gift a letter and a gift well we
don't even know each other well it's not
from me it's from from Bo oh he is so
strange yes he's a little strange but
also so human the rest of our families
are stuck in the Dark Ages or well I
don't know
Cave people perhaps Bo's different but
if they find out they'll kill him and
send me to live someplace awful like
Ohio have you ever been to Ohio sir no
well neither have I but my uncle has a
factory there he was sort of the black
sheep on account of having left but now
they tolerate him because he's a vicious
snob families are there's something else
you got a family sir [ __ ] kill you
they tolerate him good money but me with
my ideas above my station they can't
stand that sounds pretty complicated I
don't know quite what to say
nothing to say except I hope they all
rot I don't well maybe a bit but here if
you said
sure yeah sure I guess I'm just an
errand boy now don't go sneak back
through who did you do to do the horse
get over there horse god damn it horn
far away horse I'm coming nobody can see
me back let it dive loose whatever like
I'm swimming with my mouth open in the
water just hope I catch a fish my
lighter limber buddy hey a rainbow okay
dokay cart oh hey
alright okay we're doing stealthy like
who do they do deliver oh is that a
Shack oh oh
dive dive dive but no we'll just see me
in the bush
alright you use second pooping horse
horse horse I don't hear my whistling
stupid idiot so dumb horse horse not
here
oh don't worry you don't know nothing
horse jump ok never wool someone's
sneaking all the property ha you fools
yeah you ain't never gonna see me no
never again
all right back to bow bow gray you know
I got a funny feeling that this whole
story is probably not gonna end too well
for either of them if I know nothing
about Romeo and Juliet nice dildo what
the hell is this oh I believe this Buy
and it seems Colt isn't scary and I
don't like it none perla dad let the
dead bury their
all right bow-bow mission accomplished
baby mission accomplished
oh god that's an old oh this is an old
site of like a war battle this wasn't
too far removed from the Civil War I
guess I guess that's what they meant by
this is quote-unquote south but I think
it's all right here we go playing
minesweeper again dead later than that
dirt dirt there that bird on a bird at
it gates gates are for chumps and you
know what I jump excuse me um I know I'm
good thank you for the compliment the
leap leap and leap leap leap okay go
Bessie all right Bo oh hello Bo well I
feel like something's come between us
[Music]
thank you thank you
man I'm sweaty I'm moost hello what a
what a walk she drew herself killed for
sure what women's suffrage around here
they don't even like men voting bring
back the monarchy given half the chance
progress is a dirty word in these parts
unlike incest excuse me I don't want to
marry my cousin Matilda I want to marry
Penelope
but they're gonna they'll kill her at
one of those rallies they're holding
they've done it before mister you gotta
help
I don't want no part of it I'll pay my
family we still got some money fine just
no thank you come on all right I guess
we're knee-deep into this now what do we
gotta do now
mount my horse okay whatever that all I
gotta do whatever I don't want to know
that horse look listen I know you got
trampled some more people I'd listen I
don't know
all right I'll follow you I'm becoming
where else am I gonna go do whatever you
say Mel was insane
[Music]
he's now I'm actually following
automatically instead of the opposite
evening Krishna business I don't know
killed I'm prepared to die for the cause
bow you know that they need protecting
certain elements mostly my family I'll
tell you what your friend here can drive
the wagon for us my friend here says he
can drive the wagon normally I like to
drive myself but today I feel like a man
joining us since the right message well
never been in a protest march before man
well just treat us like the sheep and
the folks attack it it's like the wolves
and I'm sure you feel right at home
shall we go guys buckle up I am about to
take these ladies here we go go go oh
come on let me sprint God loose nap
there
take us down Main Street right through
town to the steps of the Callahan
O'Callahan well I'm trying to go quicker
[Music]
this is what I'm really lift you
no Babis all women voting I can't
believe it what's next damn I really
honestly truly wanted to take them off
road
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen for all of us for
today is the day we begin to live as
equals equals a fair and equal this is a
natural this is not equal and free just
us the founding fathers intended Wow
founding fathers not founding mother
darling cousin don't you ever speak to
me like that what are you doing here
listen fast fingers you got anything
better to do you always blow we just
leave who the hell is this come on guys
for him to show you it's real cool
[Music]
oh god I can't believe that like the
woman's sufferable move on just a little
over a hundred years ago why are we
going to a battlefield
shouldn't we be here weren't you worried
about some happening here it's amazing
to think of legs it's how much progress
of them I know I like I'm having fun
making jokes it's like it is crazy
[Laughter]
you mean we're dealt with our families
the graves and the braithwaite's we bury
our secrets and we bury them deep you
know Katherine braithwaite's got a
daughter
no one's seen her in years she were
right yeah and Penelope said I heard
about gold
well Yankee gold mafia that's just a
story mr. Morgan I don't know
why are we this is awful
nobody dad make that awful my cousins
are vindictive bastards
my brothers are vindictive bastards my
cousins are worse they started it I know
but you should leave I will as soon as I
have enough money when my family
we have money but I don't is your family
very rich yes well I believe so but they
keep me out of the discussions I have
more of a artistic temperament so as
ever they call it yes oh you made a joke
I really love her I do well stick around
maybe you can die for as well I thought
you were trying to make me feel better I
gotta go
me too oh damn I'm gonna be late my
uncle is quite as bad as you would
imagine here your payment thank you
excuse me okay goodbye
I don't know why you brought me out to
this field here why I would rather be at
the rally that was a pretty fun rally do
I just okay mission complete I guess
that's it that's really where it goes
that's all it goes that's all go oh come
on there's gotta be more than that I
want to see something cool happen I
wanted to take that wagon off-roading
way there's a predator predator
wait what predator is nearby I have no
idea
yeah whatever alright let's go see what
Dutch wants hey Dutch Dutch I got myself
in the middle of a familial feud I don't
know what to make of it
maybe you can shed some light on though
those deer
those are hogs all right hogs it is then
okay nope not that one not not that not
go my god are you kidding me
oh really the crested veil is really
gonna do that to me okay
let's get us some pigs I've never
skinned a pig before I don't even know
if he's Buzzard gonna bigger maybe or
all right boar come here you
where'd that other one go I know it's
over there somewhere messy business we
got to do it need to mix money it's over
here somewhere
[Music]
good God
maybe you're just bad shots good god you
guys terrible
is this what families used to do back in
that I mean I know that everything in
the game isn't exaggerating and nothing
actually is like you know like the way
it is shown here but I mean at the same
time as like is this kind of what it was
like here's a candidate it might kind of
be I don't know yeah honestly who knows
you have no space to stow them god damn
it how much how much space do I need oh
what's in my satchel I got meat that's
it I guess
I know whatever huh why do I have so
little stuff available I just want to
get rid of it I want a bigger sack
that's what I need I don't know how but
I need a bigger sack I don't know where
trapper is what I need to find one and
get a bitter sack but I don't know how
so I'm just gonna go talk to Dutch we're
gonna get some business done oh hey
[Music]
you've not been introduced mister oh I'm
so sorry sheriff are you boys had we did
well there's no need to pretend with me
sir life can be tough so I can't and no
man knows another anything no sir but
still I feel you were hard done by
losing your employment life but still
here in Rhodes we have work enough for
honest men I know that's some strong
stuff still don't seem to be doing you
any harm I guess
okay goodbye I told you he was moving up
in this world
deputies amongst these drunkards
Hillbillies and slavers good honest
thieves like us we're bound to be
moralize errs in a place like this oh
well they're just like deputy right
they're talking with my buying this may
be cost in this it's good you boys
wouldn't mind rooting it out maybe we'll
make you permanent this I gotta set me
down not a problem sir not a problem at
all you are in safe hands now and people
waste time with the temperance movement
liquor never dull the good man's senses
hell yeah baby I believe you alright
okay okay you got it buddy hey friend
good see again hey I'm uh before you
[Music]
finally someone else daily forming on
becoming a temporarily deputized citizen
of scarlet meadows county that's me baby
that's me how many hunters to do their
dirty work these days not this town he
believes the law should keep the law we
should I agree couldn't agree more no
need to remind you there's a chain of
command here of course follow my lead
and you'll be just fine
good guys guys guys guys course who else
would be but you were a big help with
them Anderson boys and I've gotten a
very good word sheriff on your behalf
good we appreciate ya round up the other
guys I'm pushing for the robot area
bill goddamn it bill William sunshiners
not just any moonshiners braithwaite's I
told you about the braithwaite's by done
don't you family had a few balls points
until well a few changes in the labor
laws now they're dealing in moonshine we
found their stills hidden all over
Lemoine quick as we destroy one another
one pops up you could call it a pitiful
fall from grace okay if they had any
grace to start with good one I have no
time for tax dodgers not to mention the
fact that Catherine Braithwaite has a
rather expensive interest in
thoroughbred horses to maintain but I
heard something about it being gold
these families were fighting over well
that's the rumor but the greys and the
braithwaite's think the other stole the
fortune from them
yeah it happened so long ago I don't
know for sure if it's true must be tough
yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway Duchess long gone Dutch is just
completely gone I don't know why but
Dutch is out of here yeah can we
skadoodle it up a little bit I don't
know how we're going so slow because I
have no idea where we're going
then maybe you could help a lot of help
maybe we could go somewhere that'd be
cool
we're not like knots good do we are
going at a glacial pace we're on the map
are we headed to right now like weird oh
my god all right that's good okay yeah
you know let's just yeah I think
something went horribly wrong so
oh just taking the countryside because I
think this is gonna take a while so I'm
gonna end this episode here for some
reason god that's beautiful but uh thank
you everybody so much for watching
Oh [ __ ] but that's one news a fun one
and look forward to more very soon and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye